okay so this is possibly one of my
favorite questions I've ever asked but
have I heard you drink sheep poo whiskey
in Tasmania and I need details
so Tasmania is a beautiful tiny sort of
little part of Australia
it only has something like 300,000
people live there but there's over
something like 60 wine distilleries
incredible whisky distillery excuse me
and so yeah we met this amazing man that
was you know brewing this incredible
whisky but everything was so resourceful
away they wasted nothing and so when I
started working with him I was shoveling
sheep and it was the Sheep that was
literally smoked in the Rye that was
starting the fermentation for the
whiskey and is actually called yo sheep
poo whiskey and honestly these
production was like 150 tiny little
bottles it was already selling out
before he'd finished it is that
sought-after Wow who knew that sheep who
could be so lucrative subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going